[Musique]
à partir de la mi-juillet la pêche de
l'ontario arrive sur les états de nos
épiceries
elle vient d'ici la vallée du niagara un
lieu unique un microclimat qui rend
possible la culture de la pêche au nord
de la frontière américaine
une sorte de protection contre le gel
belga
acx
michael est que est président de wien
lindgren un des plus importants
regroupements de producteurs de fruits à
noyaux de la vallée du niagara
en opération depuis 1913 la coopérative
compte 200 membres dont 50 producteurs
de pêches et produit 70% des pêches au
canada
la proximité des marchés permet aux
producteurs de profiter au maximum de ce
microclimat et de laisser les pêches
mourir sur l'arbre le plus longtemps
possible
depuis le mois de juillet les pêches de
l'ontario sont donc prêtes à être
cueillies
il faut donc choisir le bon moment pour
l'accueillir car la pêche est un fruit
climatériques kenneth eriksson et non
scientifiques en donne à toutes les
fruits qui peuvent durer après l'accueil
est donc par exemple on peut prendre une
tomate vert dans notre jardin la femme
ouvrir sur notre comptoir ça marche
parce que la tomate dégagent un gaz qui
s'appelle l'éthylène qui lui permet de
mûrir après la cueillette la pêche elle
peut mûrir dans nos maisons donc elle
est climatériques est dégagée l'éthylène
ce qui lui donne son super pouvoir
[Musique]
le degré de mûrissement au moment de la
cueillette est très important parce
qu'une fois que les pêches sont triés
puis expédié elle arrive dans un autre
pot comme celui ci beaucoup de pêche ici
on a des pêches de la californie on a
des pêches a encore une fois de la
californie de d'autres marques on est
des pêches la géorgie on a des pêches de
caroline du sud
l'hiver les pêches arrivent d'amérique
du sud principalement du chili
ensuite la saison commence aux états
unis en géorgie puis de plus en plus au
nord en caroline du sud en virginie où
nous jay-z et se termine en ontario et
fruits dont are you on peut vraiment les
faire muret sur la contrairement à des
fruits on va importer qui viennent de
loin qu'on doit conditionner après
l'arrivée souvent quatre cinq six jours
soit dix jours avant d'être consommables
on doit compenser bleus transport du
chili ces 21 jours voire même jusqu'à 30
jours
la pêche a donc besoin de
conditionnement pour mûrir à prouver
inconsciemment c'est de simplement
monter la température pour justement que
le fruit climatériques plus commencé sa
transformation chimique donc la réaction
du fruit va se mettre à respirer un peu
plus qui peut pas faire dans une
température très froide on doit les
emmener ses 7 degrés plus élevées ou si
on est dans la maison à température
pièce sur le comptoir des meilleurs sont
toujours ceux de l'ontario donc sont à
proximité sont proches de nous son mulet
sur l'arbre sont qui les journées
envoyés durant la nuit on les reçoit le
lendemain matin
comme les pêches continue de mûrir
jusque sur le comptoir de votre cuisine
comment les choisir les gérer et les
conserver
en général une page qui est mature va
voir les deux côtés de égale donc les
deux hémisphères de la pêche douanes de
la main crosse à la couleur est un bon
indicateur du soleil que toucher le
fruit donc moi ça ça m'attirait beaucoup
est un autre signe très facile en fait
c'est de sa mallette pressez doucement
la peau celle est très très dur ça se
peut que votre page vous restez pâteuse
pas mourir jamais comme un fruit qui va
donner juste un petit peu de poisson
peut sentir on passe un petit peu la
chair et sa cèdent sur le pouce c'est
souvent un beau signe de maturité c'est
un fruit qui est prête à manger
les agriculteurs et les grossistes
dispose de cet outil vérificateur de
pression aussi appelé un pénétromètre
sur bras un fruit qui était conditionnée
qui est plus mûr ou peut-être pas encore
prêtes à manger on va obtenir un niveau
de pression beaucoup plus beau
souvent a à peu près à 5,5 lives
effectivement il si j'obtiens trop olive
donc vous avez vu comment
l'outil est quand même bien rentrés dans
le fruit puis si je pousse avec mon
doigt je les sens j'ai vraiment il cède
sous la pression donc ce fruit doit
seraient prêtes à manger aujourd'hui
demain après-demain facilement et il
sent très bon et l'odeur aussi une pêche
qui bien moeurs votre dégagé vraiment au
dakar et pc donc si vous sentez rien
c'est pas bon c'est non on me dit bon
vieux pagne en carton avec la poignée
mais on a aussi maintenant des paniers
en plastique comme celui là c'est
difficile des touches et puis les
sentiers des emballages comme ça mais
les producteurs font ça parce que
justement les gens ont tendance à
beaucoup touché les pages qu'on va les
acheter donc à chaque fois que quelqu'un
me toucha brise les cellules
s'approfondit brunissement à l'intérieur
[Musique]
on tente de protéger la pêche mais le
panier de plastique recyclable est
utilisée avant tout pour des raisons
sanitaires et plusieurs grandes
bannières préfère ce type de contenant
parce qu'en plus de protéger le fruit il
aide aussi à conserver son humidité
dans le clan dans la maison on les place
comme sur les étals sur un plateau pour
éviter que ça soit une par dessus
l'autre est aussi son voeu que ce soit
au tout près en même temps on prend même
les étaler dans plusieurs contenants
dans notre cuisine que me voyez
l'exemple ici la dépêche du fonds les
fruits c'est vivant donc des blessés
comme ça ça les stresse un fric et ce
récit reste le plus vite vous consommez
moins longtemps mûri plus vite dans son
voeu peau on veut vraiment resserré
pour ralentir son mûrissement on le
refroidit donc direction frigo
[Musique]
oh
ou encore mieux les manger
trickett axa là
[Musique]